the whole of humanity is here it's uh
it's Vanity Fair what are you most
excited to see tonight
to see yeah well I know that you
probably watched a few of the movies are
you excited to see anybody win do you
have your hopes up for anyone
um
not no no one in particular okay
look tonight then
adjust my suit your suit who made yours
you didn't make it make it um I can't
remember my tailor that's okay shout out
to the tailor yeah
um so tell me what does it feel like to
be in Glass Onion it was such an amazing
film I really loved it I love a thriller
how fun is it to shoot something like
that well I'm barely in it I'm in it for
about three seconds yeah
showed up and you had fun right uh
almost okay
okay back to you guys